do you know more people who enjoy dating
or who complain about dating I feel like
most people complain about dating why do
you think that is because they're not
happy in their relationships
now if there was one thing that you wish
that men understood better about women
what would it be
um how to be more catering because I'm
tired of giving
you said catering yes because I give
more than I receive
so would you say that reciprocity is key
in relationships yes
now
um do you feel like um who do you think
typically uh invests more into building
a relationship with the man or the woman
the woman of course well like like what
exactly does a woman do to kind of build
a relationship as opposed to what a man
does well I feel like we're more
supportive first off and we're going to
do more because we want to see you
succeed more and I feel like most men
aren't doing that
I mean I I grew up with this all the
time it's about like the guy doesn't
treat me well he's not nice enough he's
not doing he's not holding the door for
me and I've also been that guy who's
done all of that and you are overlooked
overshadowed easily by the guy who
treats you like [ __ ] and is an absolute
douchebag so well I see what I think of
like traditional it's like the guy
picking you up taking you out to dinner
holding the doors paying for the date
um and you know waiting for sex
I mean yeah I think that all that all
though that lies on the woman though
like that's the power the woman has and
they'll put this ideal up on a pedestal
of what a man should be and what they
want and then what they actually go seek
out is the entire opposite and as
someone who there's a lot of men out
there just have a good heart and just
want to be hurt and really appreciated
for that and a lot of times you don't
feel like you can show that because once
you show that compassion once you show
your true colors
it's looked at as a weakness you know I
feel men have to be the providers men
have to to you know basically give up
their entire lives to please a woman
when men you know we're only worth what
we can provide women are worth
just just for their looks or for for you
know basic things but we need to provide
everything in a relationship or in any
aspect of life and even if you're able
to you know attract a woman are you able
to keep her keep her happy keep her
satisfied unless you can meet her list
no
so you think that women are really more
interested in the situation than they
are in the actual man
yeah I do
why do women divorce men 70 to 80
percent of the time 90 of their college
educated
I don't know I just heard that one too
um
like have more unconditional love
doesn't it seem like then men would
well from what
um
um I've seen that and it usually
um I've seen that most of the divorces
are uh instigated by women
they said that men are I don't really
know the answer to that I know on the
other side men are just more willing to
stick something out and just work at it
even though they're unhappy and if a man
typically has to have looks money and
status in order to attract lots of
beautiful women how is the man not
considered the prize
because
a man
a Man Loves a Woman doesn't a woman love
a man a woman does love a man but a
woman loves money more
so do you think women are more
interested in love or power power power
of the punani yeah what exactly does
that mean
the power it's the power that a woman
has naturally like her superpower
basically that's what grabs a man that's
What Makes a Man want you to begin with
he doesn't even know you it's just
you're a woman and what's the difference
between using power and abusing power
using it is basically just utilizing it
for its purpose abusing it is uh
making using it for your advantage but
it's going to be at a disadvantage for
that other person so when it comes to
the power of punani do you think that
women are more likely to use or abuse
that power
in general
it probably abuse it
uh so why isn't that given more
attention
because men are not really going to
complain about it it's
you know you just Chuck it up that's
just part of the game like you know you
uh you get played sometimes
it's very rare that I've ever felt that
I can open up to a woman because usually
once you do it kind of comes off as red
flags it comes off as needy oh he's the
nice guy those kind of aspects and they
want some to take charge they want
someone who's got their [ __ ] together
and it's almost like it's always
convoluted and the message is never on
par it's you're asking for this you're
getting that and there's no middle
ground and it's yeah it's so it's very
easy for women to kind of move on from a
man if you're not meeting those
attributes so if women became more aware
of these double standards and men's
issues
how much do you think would actually
change
I would hope more uh uh I can't say for
sure I mean I've had these taught
discussions prior and
um it seems to get heated and women go
you don't know what you're talking about
so you kind of brush it aside and try
and find a way around it but I mean have
you found
women who are more receptive to these
issues than other women yeah yes
absolutely I've got some great friends
who are very empathetic very
compassionate and I think the world of
them but uh as a whole most men don't
get the experience that and they aren't
treated that way by the majority of
women now what are your thoughts on the
expression women don't care about a
man's struggles they just want to show
up at the finish line and pick the
winners
um I honestly you said women don't care
about a man's struggles basically modern
women today don't care about a man's
struggles they just want to show up at
the finish line and pick oh I think that
that's true because someone like me I'm
going to be there for you and support
you but these new age girls I don't know
about them they are just ridiculous and
I feel like they're only in it to get
what they can get out of it so so why do
you think there's the expression where
of all the good men gone but nobody's
asking where have all the good women
gone
um well we're of all the good man good
all the good men gone they're stupid
because they're dating these younger
women and they're getting used so the
reason why there's so many good women
out here is because we're being looked
over do you think that when they they
say that like the answer to where of all
the good men gone is in your 20s like
where it's like an expression where
women would look over the good men in
their 20s and like pick the bad boys and
then and then in their 30s they're like
oh we'll take me now but it's like they
got they're they're kind of salty
because we overlooked them in our 20s
um so yeah we do Overlook them in our
20s and I can say we go Overlook them in
our 30s because I've been stuck with
some bad men in the 30s and technically
I feel like now it's kind of like there
are really no good men I haven't found a
good guy so we do Overlook it now uh has
ever been a man you wanted that you
weren't able to get well I'd like to
talk about Bruno Mars I do want him and
if he met me he'd want me to now if you
had the opportunity to hook up with
Bruno Mars would you take it I sure
would so when a woman says that I'm not
that type of girl isn't she really
saying I'm not that type of girl with
you but I am that type of girl with a
guy like Bruno Mars no because I'm going
to be myself with him regardless of who
he is
so I if he's going to like me for who I
am then he's going to see that I'm a
good woman regardless of anything do you
think it's true that women will make
rules for the wrong guy but break rules
for the right guy I do I do as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible